so our next speaker is molly author
western we'll be talking about designing
adaptive experiments and uh
thank you very much
thank you so much um
this workshop has really been a pleasure
to attend and hear about everything that
you're all working on so i'm really
excited to present this work to you as
well i'm going to be following along in
kind of the policy oriented theme that
avi just started for us
i'm a political scientist i'm trained
jointly in political science and
statistics i'm at the university of
chicago and i'll be talking about
designing adaptive experiments for
policy makers primarily so we're at this
really exciting frontier in experimental
design where we can use adaptive
experiments these are really great
designs they allow researchers and
policy makers to do all these things you
can select among alternatives
efficiently
you get to assign more observations to
those interventions that are most
effective you can improve outcomes for
respondents as you go which is something
that policymakers care a lot about
but as a practitioner as a policy maker
how would you go about designing an
adaptive experiment that's appropriate
for your objectives and so this is
motivated by very real concerns i got an
email from the french employment agency
from a woman who works there about 10
days ago they're running an adaptive
experiment they're really excited about
this they found the design document for
an experiment that i had run last summer
with susan avey and leah rosenzwig
they're using the algorithm that we have
proposed there they had questions about
how they should go about actually
running this experiment so these designs
are really exciting and really great but
we need to make sure that they're going
to be relevant for the policy makers for
the practitioners who are using these
methods and this is something that i
kind of want to come back to as well is
that
these designs we often know how they'll
perform asymptotically but we need to do
a lot more thinking about how they'll
actually perform in the sample sizes and
in the settings that policy makers are
going to be using
them so this talk is about how to design
adaptive experiments
when you do care about inference how to
think about writing a design document in
the setting and some principles for
decision making
so there's this really exciting rapidly
growing literature on inference for
adaptive experiments this is a really
great literature i think it's really
really important we care about
connecting these things but a lot of
this literature comes from the
perspective of if you already have
adaptively collected data conditional on
having this data what can you do with it
to do off-policy evaluation and to do
inference this is really important but
as a practitioner how do you set
yourself up at the design stage
to get adaptively collected data to run
your experiment that's best going to
serve your objectives
and so this is relevant for policy
makers but i think it's relevant for all
of us who work in this space in terms of
recommending these methods and thinking
about principles for these methods that
will make them relevant for the people
who are actually using them
so
policy makers care about
rigorously establishing evidence
they care about maximizing welfare and
minimizing harm they actually care as
they're running the experiment about not
assigning harmful treatments to people
about not giving people interventions
that are ineffective when they have
alternatives that might be more
effective
and they may care most
about learning most about the policies
that are most effective right so for a
policy that's ineffective or that's
harmful they may only need to know that
it's worse than the alternatives for
policy that's highly effective they
might want to get very precise estimates
they might want to be able to say pretty
precisely
how that is going to affect a larger
population
this is also relevant for researchers so
i speak to political scientists and i
try and convince them as well that we
care about running adaptive experiments
not just for policy relevant reasons but
it's also relevant for
theory so you might say when you're
running an experiment
you want to use the best
operationalization of that treatment and
we often when we often run an
experimental experiment we often just
start with some operationalization of
treatment and we just kind of assume
that that's what it is and we condition
on that but there might be a full set of
treatments whose content is consistent
with our research question and so we can
think about using adaptive designs to
search across those alternatives to
get better uh to get closer to the
theories that we're investigating right
so you might have different versions of
treatment that are all consistent with
some questions but some of them are more
effective at moving a mechanism
and so we can think about searching
across those and being able to test
hypotheses that are closer to the things
that we actually care about
so when i talk about adaptive
experiments i am talking about response
adaptive experiments these types of
designs that address the multi-armed
bandit problem
these are the types of algorithms that
we've been speaking about over the past
few days that are navigating this
explore and exploit trade-off where you
want to learn something about the
treatment response space
and you also want to exploit the
treatments that are going to be most
effective for you this is also the
problem the policy maker is facing they
want to learn about different
interventions but they want to start
applying those interventions that are
going to be most effective
and so we can run we can use these
designs to run experiments with multiple
treatments more efficiently
but these adaptive algorithms they
weren't originally designed with
inference and hypothesis testing in mind
so we need to need to make these
connections back to the statistical
literature to get valid inference
and we often may not want to use these
algorithms just out of the box as
they're designed they're often designed
to maximize welfare minimize regret
which are things that the policy makers
care about but it's not the only thing
and they're not designed to provide
inferential leverage and so we might
want to think about how we can tweak
these algorithms or how we should apply
them to meet all of the objectives that
we might have
okay so we do know some things about
inference with respect to adaptively
collected data so let's say that you
want to design adaptive experiment where
should you start
so we know first of all that if we
ignore the method of data collection and
we just use sample means with adaptively
collected data we're going to get
estimates that are negatively biased
so i have a nice toy example that i'm
not going to walk through here but it'll
be in the slides if you want to look at
it that basically shows how this comes
about and it's because you're selecting
on the outcomes so in an adaptive
algorithm if an arm performs well just
by chance just by random chance you're
going to sample more from that arm
you'll have more observations from that
arm and so your estimate for response
under that arm is going to be corrected
so you'll get a better estimate if you
have an arm that performs poorly just by
chance you're going to have a negatively
biased estimate for that arm and you
might sample less from that arm you're
less likely to see that arm again and so
your bias might persist so on average we
can end up with bias if we just ignore
the data collection
a really nice solution to this is
inverse probability weighted estimators
so here this is just the orbitz thompson
estimator where the idea is that you are
waiting by the inverse probability of
receiving the treatment
that you were actually assigned
here i'm going to assume that we're
using an algorithm where these
probabilities never go to zero you
always have a positive probability for
every observation of receiving every
treatment
and we can show that if we use these
estimators and adaptively collected data
these estimators are fine and unbiased
and i have it in my toy example as well
so it's nice to work through it you can
see where the bias comes from and you
can see that the estimator fully removes
the source of bias so this is a really
great solution for these settings
the drawback is if there's low overlap
between the policy that you want to
evaluate and an actual assigned policy
you're going to end up with high
variance so these
treatment assignment probabilities will
be low your variance will blow up you'll
have fewer observations and you'll get a
bad estimate so for example for an arm
that performs poorly you're not
assigning it with very high probability
you're not getting a lot of observations
on the other hand for arms that perform
well you're going to assign more
treatment to those arms your treatment
assignment probabilities will be higher
and you'll get more precise estimates so
this is one of these trade-offs with
inference when we think about adaptively
collected data
we can also do covariate adjustments
these are doubly robust estimators so
this is something that ivy mentioned as
well so you have this estimated outcome
model you have this residual bias
correction
this is just an augmented inverse
probability weighted estimators there
are different estimators that you can do
use that can do this you can use tmle
there are different approaches
there are
some slight complications with using the
estimated outcome model on adaptively
collected data season 80 and victor
haddad have some work on the future out
estimators so there are some tweaks that
you make to this but in general this is
another great solution to
estimation with adaptively collected
data
so great we have some approaches to
estimation
but there are still some challenges with
getting confidence intervals um raz
indicated this the other day it's not
trivial to get valid confidence
intervals with adaptively collected data
so this is from a paper
by victor haddad who's an atheist stefan
wagger
david hershberg and rohan zhang that
i'll talk about again in just a second
you can see that even when we use
inverse probability weighted estimators
the distribution of the estimator is
non-normal with adaptively collected
data and so we need to account for that
when we're thinking about generating
confidence intervals
there's some various solutions
for what we can do in those settings
haddad and co-authors have this approach
where they adaptively reweight the two
different terms of the augmented inverse
probability weighted estimator so
they're controlling for the
contributions of the ver to the variance
of those two different terms
this does require that those propensity
scores those treatment assignment
probabilities decay at a relatively slow
rate
this does affect the regret that you get
but it's a trade-off that you have here
if your algorithm is too aggressive and
you're not assigning some arms
anymore you're not going to be able to
get those valid confidence intervals
dashpandy and co-authors have another
approach where you have this
ols estimator that's augmented with a w
decoration matrix which does basically
what it says in the tin it's this extra
mess matrix that's removing the
correlation due to the the nature of the
adaptively collected data and then zhang
and co-authors at susan murphy's lab
have this approach with batched ols
hypothesis testing the idea is if you're
assigning your
policy in a batchwise approach so you
learn a policy and then for the next x
observations you assign that policy
within batches your ols estimates are
asymptotically normally distributed so
you can use your statistics from within
a batch
combine them across batches i hope i'm
describing this correctly
combine them across matches and then
compare it to a simulated null
distribution but to do that you also
need to have a batched uh assignment
yes
um
so you're saying that there's an
alternative estimator that gets valid
confidence intervals
there's a reason why
and there are many issues for example
perfectly
things
yeah so i'm not familiar with that but i
so these works are mostly dealing with
index-based policies
which did not necessarily always have
[Music]
acquire data
um
but if you're looking for policies that
are locked
there's a lot of work by
folks from microsoft like others
and
those kind of guys and then there's
a lake
these
alternative proposals for estimators for
different types of algorithms
um
we may have to look at how nonparametric
are parametric yeah
but from what i know they are quite
nonparametric
yeah i think this is a really exciting
growing space in literature where people
are starting to address these types of
problems so i show that there are lots
of solutions that i'm not aware of um
yes a quick follow-up so i think in a
lot of policy like the work
i might be wrong but the policy is fixed
and this is like policies evolving over
time
so that's like one subtle difference
like here the policy depends on the data
there enough policy literature the
logging policy is fixed it doesn't adapt
over time i mean not necessarily so
these could be fixed policies as well
but with the documentation so the policy
applied in the experiment is changing
over time but the policy data that i'll
be writing doesn't necessarily happen so
the chavez result
is conditioned on the data that you
observed
so they had this problem but then they
fixed it in the recent paper okay they
fixed for exxon and then they
did never confidently kept off okay
let's follow up on this i would love to
hear more about it
um so there are additional solutions
in addition to these ones that might
address some of these issues
um
an alternative approach
sorry so so when we're using these
methods you still need an appropriate
design right you need to have sufficient
probability floors or probability
weights that decay sufficiently slowly
you may need to use batchwise assignment
um so you need to account for your
design when you're using these methods
an alternative approach is a
design-based approach so what you could
do is you have a learning phase where
you collect your data adaptively you
learn a policy on that learning phase
and then you can have an evaluation
phase where you do your evaluation when
you're assigned the policy that you want
to learn about on policy and often this
is much easier to get right
based on my awareness i think this is
what's done most often in industry
settings i think at facebook at core
data science they'll often run bandits
and then if they want to evaluate it
they'll do something that is just um
assigning the policy or a set of
policies that they're interested in in a
non-adaptive approach i'd be super
interested to hear if people know other
approaches that are being used in
industry settings but i think for policy
settings this can often be
very well motivated if you want to make
the case for a given policy this might
give you the most compelling evidence to
have really good data on it
and if you're evaluating a complicated
contextual policy you might get really
much better returns to efficiency by
evaluating on policy so with adaptively
collected data there's lots of potential
areas for low overlap there might be
some spaces treatment covariate
combinations where you have a really low
probability of assignment whereas if you
assign on
policy you can be assured to get good
overlap
we have also found that trying to do
policy learning contextual policy
learning and evaluation on the same set
of data can be quite the same sort of
adaptively collected data can be quite
challenging so this is one easier
solution to doing that
there are potential concerns right if
you have a separate learning and
evaluation phase you can deal with
covariate shift so you could have
different distributions of covariates in
the evaluation phase as compared to the
learning phase we do have really good
tools for um adjusting for that if you
just assume that it's based on the
observable covariates
and if you select the wrong arm or the
wrong policy
you have no chance of getting more data
in that evaluation phase on the true
best policy and so then a question that
you need to ask yourself or that the
policy maker needs to ask themselves is
how much does this matter to them right
are they happy enough to get good
inference on an arm that is good enough
that is maybe not the true best arm that
is close to it um
[Music]
do they care about getting something
that is within delta of the true best
arm or do they really need to get the
best arm whereas if you keep on
collecting data adaptively you still
have a chance to get more data on that
true best arm and to correct yourself
so
trade-offs to consider
okay so we have some ideas about how to
do inference and adaptively collected
data we have some ideas about the
estimators and procedures that we might
use
and so
my recommendation is like that just with
like with any randomized control trial
you should start with a design document
and this is a question that i've got
multiple times is how do you write a
design document how do you think about
doing power calculations when you're
going to let your algorithm go and you
don't know which arms are going to be
selected as best you don't know how much
data is going to be collected you don't
know what the probability weights are
but i would say that with adaptively
collected data it's even more important
because the parameters that you choose
are really going to affect the data that
you get in the end so you really need to
make these design decisions at the
outset of your design to make sure that
you're going to set yourself up to get
the data that you need
so we need to think about what
hypotheses we're trying to test
adaptively collected data generally does
not position us well to make comparisons
across arms right we might have one arm
that ends up getting a lot of data one
arm that doesn't get very much data and
so if your objective is to make multiple
comparisons across these arms
non-adaptive rcts might be better for
that objective
what we can do is we could say test a
hypothesis about each arm independently
say that the arm meme is different from
zero and we're going to trade off on
average good power for those arms that
are performing well that we get a lot of
data on with bad power for arms that are
performing poorly so that's a trade-off
that we have to be okay with we have to
decide we're okay with if we're using an
adaptive experiment
if your control condition is known
ex-ante if you know you want to run an
experiment you know what the control is
you can account for this in your
algorithm don green alex coppic and i
have proposed a control augmented
algorithm where you assign more data to
your control condition as you go through
the experiment so it's matching with
your
arm that's getting the most treatment
assigned there are different approaches
you can take to that but it's something
you need to consider if you know that
you want to have a control
making hypotheses ex ante about what's
going to be the best arm can be tricky
and we can think about this if we have
two fair coins we don't know that
they're fair
and you want to make an estimate of the
probability of getting heads under what
what you think is going to be the best
point
so one method that you could take to
doing this would be you could flip both
of these coins a number of times say
you've flipped them 100 times
one of your coins gets heads 55 times
one of them gets heads 45 times the one
that gets had 55 times you say okay i
think that's my best coin and i think
that the mean
success rate the mean number of heads
under that is 0.55
doing this conditioning on outcomes is
going to give you a biased estimate even
though both of the coins were fair if
you had picked either one of the four
coins at random you'd get an unbiased
estimate of the best coin because
they're both fair but if you condition
on outcomes using this type of approach
you'll get a bias estimate and we'll
have the same problem if we look at
adaptively collected data see which arm
appears to be performing best and just
estimate response of the best arm
conditional on that
so the different approach that we can
take is to repeat those steps one and
two above that we
flip each of these coins a bunch of
times we see which which coin we think
is best then we stop and we take that
point that we think is best and flip it
some other number of times we flip it
again a bunch of times and we use only
those flips
to get an estimate of its mean response
this will produce an unbiased estimate
and this is kind of the same idea of
having that learning and evaluation
phase you're separating your learning
from your evaluation phase
we can think about doing this with
adaptively collected data so here this
is a hypothesis with respect to
the batchwise rolling best arm so we
could say that
at time t we can use data from batches
of adaptively collected data up to time
t minus one
learn which arm we think is best based
on the estimates from that data
evaluate that arm in time t
in time t plus one use the data all the
way up to time t see which arm we think
is best evaluate that in time t plus one
and so we have this kind
of rolling estimate of which arm we
think is best
this gives us an unbiased estimate but
it is kind of a bit of a weird policy
right because the arm that we think is
best is itself random but this is the
same kind of idea of separating that
learning and evaluation phase and just
doing that in a rolling manner as we go
so i'm going to walk through an example
briefly of an adaptive experiment that
i'm running right now
to show how we thought about making some
of these decisions
so
global availability of copin 19 vaccines
is growing however there are still
problems of vaccine hesitancy which is
limiting governability to distribute
them so this new york times article
references sub-saharan african countries
in south asia the project that i'm
working on focuses particularly on
sub-saharan africa on kenya and nigeria
and the question that we're asking in
this study is can we train a chatbot a
facebook messenger chatbot to optimize
messaging in response to people's stated
vaccine concerns so the idea is people
tell us what their concerns are we give
them some messaging the eventual
objective is that message messaging
addresses those concerns and makes
people less hesitant to take the vaccine
and hopefully eventually get vaccinated
this is joint work with leah rosensweig
who is a director at the development
innovation lab at the becker friedman
institute at the university of chicago
this is michael kramer's new institute
this is supported by work
by the busara center for behavioral
economics in kenya nigeria
and it's funded by the vaccine
confidence fund which is a project by
facebook and merck
so started here with focus groups and
the point that i am making is that
um
when you are running these adaptive
experiments you can look across a number
of treatments and figure out which
version of treatment appears to be most
effective which policy appears to be
most effective but if all of your
treatments all of your versions of
treatment are garbage you can use the
best technology to select amongst them
and you're going to have garbage in and
garbage out and so it is really
important as a policy maker as a
practitioner to make sure that you have
treatments that are going to give you a
chance at being effective so we started
with focus group discussions we had
conversations with people about what
their concerns were i did not our
implementing partners did
about what their concerns were
and what types of information they would
be interested in for addressing those
concerns
we had targeted facebook ads and when
people clicked the ads they started a
conversation with their chatbot and
messenger just a quick aside i have
found that this is a really nice way to
conduct surveys um it's a really nice
way to reach out to people in
sub-saharan africa many people their
their entree into the internet is
through facebook we can do this on
facebook basic or facebook lite apps
that people have on their phone that are
very low data so it's very accessible to
people to have these messenger
conversations with us and as you're
having this conversation it's just a
very nice comfortable natural way to go
through these questions and to discuss
these topics
so we ask people their thoughts about
the vaccine their concerns for people
who had not yet received a vaccine we
asked their primary concern these were
categorized based on our focus group
discussions and then we tested different
messaging in response to those concerns
so for example if people said that their
primary concern is vaccine side effects
we had a number of different messages
that we could give to them that it would
address those concerns and again the
content of these messages came from our
focus group discussions of what people
thought would be most effective
so then we have to select our algorithm
we care about selecting the best
versions of the messages and so you can
think about you know when you're picking
your algorithm do you care about best
arm selection do you also care about
inference do you care about minimizing
regret so you can hear about contextual
policy learning
for us we care about best arm
identification conditional on concern
category so for each concern category
we're running a separate adaptive
experiment and so we want to find the
best message for each concern
and so the algorithm that we ended up
using is top 2 thomson sampling which is
optimal in the sense that
the posterior probability of selecting
an arm that is not optimal as the
optimal arm under the algorithm
converges to
zero at a nice rate
there are some different algorithms that
you can use here this is a fairly easy
to implement one what it basically looks
like is you use thompson sampling to
learn which charm is best you assign
that arm with some probability then you
amongst the remaining arms you figure
out which arm is best you assign that
arm with some probability here we have
it just split equally between those top
two arms we actually also have
probability floors so we're assigning
all of the other arms with some minimal
probability as well
so
a question then is you have this
adaptive algorithm how do you think
about sample size determination if you
care about inference you might think
about power calculations and normally
with a power calculation you're figuring
how much data you need you don't know
here how much data you're going to
assign to the different arms and so how
do you think about doing something like
a power calculation or for sample size
determination how much data you'll need
to figure out which arm is best
if you have an algorithm that's able to
determine which arm is the best arm
really quickly you're going to get a lot
of data for that arm you'll get really
good estimates for that arm
but you might
not be in that version and so we can
think about what is a feasible
worst case version of the world that you
could be in for the objective that you
care about
so our objective is best arm
identification conditional in the
concern category
where the outcome is binary response we
ask people did this message address your
concern so we start with a mean of 0.5
to maximize variance very similar to how
you would under a power calculation
and then we can say what if the best arm
is only 0.01 points better than the
second best arm we're going to have a
hard time differentiating between those
two
and to do these types of simulations to
figure out what this is going to look
like we need to also posit what all of
the sub-optimal arms are going to look
like as well we need to know the full
distribution of response under all of
the arms so we could say what if the
second best arm is only 0.01 points
better than the remaining arms
well now we know how all of the arms but
their distribution of responses and we
can run a full simulation under a
proposed algorithm
but you could say you know that means
all of the arms have about the same
um response rates that they're all going
to have pretty similar success this is
not a very large difference and maybe my
objective actually accounts for some
kind of simple regret that i only you
know
if these are all really similar arms
that i might not get the best arm all
the time but i'm going to get something
that is within delta of the best arm so
maybe i don't care that much about it
maybe i want to say if the best arm is
0.05 points better than the next best
arm how often am i going to find that
arm and so when we think about running
these simulations you need to think
about what your objective actually is
and
when you need to be able to
differentiate across arms
so this is one version of the world this
is one type of simulation we could run
where we positive what the distribution
of response was under all of the
different arms here i think you can't
see that well but we have different
estimators so we have haya corvitz
thompson and the sample mean and we can
see that with the hayek and sample mean
estimators were doing a pretty good job
for using those to select which arm is
best this is when we ran the experiment
under simulation a thousand times and
saw how often we were able to correctly
select the best arm and we see that
after you know like
830 900 observations we're selecting the
best arm about 75 of the time we see
what the horrible thompson estimated
that i was recommending before that
we're actually doing a worse job of
selecting the best arm that estimator
has higher variance and so we're better
off using the sample mean or the hayek a
stabilized inverse probability weighted
estimator to do that arm selection and
we can think about different types of
simulations that we might run we might
say you know what's the proportion of
times that i'll pick the best arm or the
second best norm if that's the thing
that we care about
um determining the feasible worst case
or figuring out how to do these
simulations is slightly more challenging
in the contextual case
and so maybe one approach to thinking
about this is what if the optimal
contextual policy is only delta standard
deviations better than the best fixed
policy how long will i need to run my
experiment to learn a contextual policy
that will be better than the best policy
in that setting and how long will i need
to run it to be able to differentiate
between those two inferentially
for estimating procedures this is just
to show you quickly so this is a version
of the experiment where i've posited
what the response values are
so we have response of 0.49 0.49 0.5 and
0.455
we can see that the sample mean is
actually giving us negatively biased
estimates
whereas the hayek and the orbitz
thompson estimators these inverse
probability weighted estimators are
giving us unbiased estimates on average
and so
the amount of bias that we're getting
from the sample mean is less for that
arm that's performing well but it's
still there in an experiment of about
size 1000 so i might like to use
something like the hayek estimator
that's going to do a good job of
selecting the best arm excuse me and
it's going to be unbiased
i'm just going to run through a last
couple of thoughts before wrapping up
the sample means pretty well for best
time selection but it's systematically
biased it can also happen that our
algorithm selects the best arm that is
not consistent with what we get if we
use inverse probability weighted
estimates and this is something that
i've seen happen a number of times
actually running adaptive experiments um
that your algorithm that you're using
it's not counting for these treatment
assignment probabilities and so your
algorithm itself can be biased and so
one solution for this is using these
balancing weights proposed by dima
coppulo and susan ep
that's basically updating your algorithm
and incorporating those treatment
assignment probabilities as an
adjustment into the algorithm
we can think about some other design
parameters we can think about whether we
want to run our experiment online or
batch either way i think it's a pretty
good idea to have a large first batch
that helps with the stability of your
algorithm
we can think about probability floors so
there are all these decisions that we
can think about and we need to
incorporate them into our simulations as
we are setting up our design document
and see how our algorithm will actually
run
if we're operating under these specified
conditions
so these are the results from the study
i'm just going to jump to the end though
we can talk about these actual results
afterwards if anyone's interested
but the big takeaways
are
design documents are if anything i think
even more important for adaptive studies
as compared to non-adaptive studies
um to do these design documents you need
to determine what your objectives are
you need to determine what hypotheses
you might test
you need to be explicit about your
algorithm this is something that i found
surprising is that often people
write their algorithms down in very
general forms i think it's useful if you
can include your code if possible to be
very precise about what parameters
you're using
and how you're implementing it and then
conduct sample size determination via
simulations when you're running these
simulations consider what the feasible
worst case scenario could be
uh we have a shiny app here that was set
up by myself victor haddad and susan
athe for one of season's classes but i
think it's a really nice way to
run through what these different
parameters these different design
decisions can do in terms of informing
how your experiments can play out
and thank you very much to my various
collaborators on different parts of
these projects
thank you
we'll set up the panel